one could say you measure it by results
but I think it goes a lot deeper than
that and i would say that to me great
business leadership is somebody with a
heightened sensitivity to the idea that
everyone who works for them really wants
to be a success I've never met anybody
in my life who us do you want to be a
success that said no so if you can spend
your life as a leader encouraging other
people and supporting them to become
successes then I think you're a great
leader and if you look at people with
those skills that's something to do very
very well and it's not just about
rewarding with money it's a sensitivity
to making them better helping them
supporting them understanding them
understanding also what they're trying
to achieve if you get that down
you